okay so
um we should get started uh welcome to
um the the second uh simon's institute
open lecture of this semester
so as many of you probably know these
lectures uh
are an occasion in which we invite
distinguished visitors to the simons
institute
to speak to a broad scientific audience
and uh eliminate some of the ideas that
are being discussed
in the institute's programs so this this
semester we're running
two programs uh one on quantum
hamiltonian complexity which is the
subject of today's talk
and the other on evolutionary biology in
the theory of computing
so both of these programs are a good
illustration of the
one of the main goals of the institute
which is to
apply concepts from the theory of
computation to
other scientific disciplines and explore
connections with them
disciplines such as okay
disciplines such as physics chemistry
economics biology and so on
so in particular in the quantum
hamiltonian complexity program we have
uh computer scientists and uh condensed
matter
physicists rubbing shoulders and trying
to understand
some fundamental properties of quantum
systems
um so with that in mind let me introduce
today's speaker dorita haranov from the
hebrew university in jerusalem
um so so dorita has been a professor of
computer science in jerusalem
since 2001 and she also did a phd there
in the intervening years she she spent
time as a postdoc and was a visiting
scientist in
various other places including caltech
and
the institute for advanced study in
princeton and also
uh pleased to say uc berkeley several
times
she also she comes from a family of
distinguished physicists and
mathematicians and she was
apparently i grew up on einstein street
in haifa
and uh therefore it's not that
surprising that she chose
the career path that she did um
so in the meantime dorita's become
recognized as one of the leaders of the
field of quantum computation and
we're very pleased that she's been able
um to spend substantial time at the
program this semester she's one of the
organizers of the program and also
was a co-organizer last week of a very
successful workshop on quantum games and
protocols
her research interests span a very broad
range of topics in quantum computing
including quantum fault tolerance
quantum algorithms quantum cryptography
and the emerging field of quantum
hamiltonian complexity
and connections between quantum
mechanics and the traditional
classical computational complexity and
indeed that's that's the topic of
today's talk maybe she'll also explain
this picture of the tiger as well
so thanks a lot aleister for this very
nice introduction
and it's an honor to be here and um
okay so um so what i tell what i want to
talk about today is really to tell you a
little bit about what's going on in the
quantum
tuning complexity program um
and maybe at the end we'll understand
also this logo of the program
so if i don't get to it ask me um
okay so so so we really in this program
study
quantum mechanics now quantum mechanics
is a theory that has been
really tested and there have been
hundreds
of thousands of experiments probably
testing it and it's
highly established and still it's very
common practice
to to say that we don't understand
quantum mechanics
um so there's there's this famous saying
if you think you understand quantum
mechanics
they don't understand quantum mechanics
and really i actually don't understand
this thing because also if you don't
think that
you also don't understand and it's it's
uh
it's usually attributed to fine bun but
find one but i think it's by
only by default um there's no evidence
that feynman said it but in any case
this is it's sort of common practice to
say we don't understand quantum
mechanics
so let's just review the basic
principles of quantum mechanics that we
say we don't understand
okay so so there are two such basic
principles i want to
focus on one is the superposition
principle which says
the the highly counterintuitive thing
that
a quantum system can be in a
superposition a linear combination
of all its possible classical states
so for example a spin that can point up
and down
can also be in a linear combination of
of those states
and likewise a cat can be both dead and
alive at the same time
and we have this beautiful mathematical
formalism
um of assigning to to such a quantum
system say it has
two states so we call it a quantum bit
or a qubit
um a hilbert space a vector space of
dimension two
and we have uh we have um
two basis vectors that correspond to
those classical states
uh and but in general a quantum state is
this linear combination of these two
basis states denoted with these
uh up and down for example so in general
we have
some vector a linear combination of
those states
okay so this is really a
counter-intuitive basic principle and
then there is the other basic
principle which is the measurement
principle which is also highly
counter-intuitive
it says the following suppose i want to
to measure
the system um in this
funny state superposition state then the
outcome
is if i measure it in the in the basis
up and down the outcome will be either
up or down probabilistically so
the the uh quantum mechanic says that
there is absolutely
no way to predict the outcome of uh
of the system even if you know exactly
the quantum state
so the outcome will be probabilistic and
the and as
as you probably know the the
probabilities depend on the coefficients
in front of the
up or down but but the point is that you
cannot really predict what's going on
and this
these two principles are really highly
counter-intuitive
so okay so they are so counter-intuitive
that
it's hard to swallow and uh and many
people
try to to find ways to um to bypass
bypass those uh those principles
and so is it possible to maybe move like
this
to have someone sort of shift this so
that
okay so um okay so
einstein podolski rosen famously found
this uh
epr paradox which sort of tries to put
uh to point at the problem in quantum
mechanics so tries to say that
quantum mechanics is incomplete um and
basically
what uh what they did is is they took um
well i'm not going to explain the epr
paradox exactly
but but they they looked at the quantum
state which
which is uh which is very interesting
which is called the epr pair
and that quantum state is a state of two
particles
which are in superposition so
if the first particle points up the
second particle
particle is in the state down and if the
other if this first particle is down the
second particle is up
so they're in superposition of both
these configurations
okay so what they showed what what they
they basically pointed at is that this
highly
correlated state um
sort of leads to something which is
which
einstein like to call a spooky action at
the distance
so basically this this epr state
is highly quality not only in in the
basis of up and down but in any basis
that you look at it
they're highly correlated and these
correlations seem too strong
and it took 30 years for john bell to
actually find
a more mathematically rigorous way to
say this thing
and to find inequalities called bill
inequalities
such that any physical theory that is
not so counter-intuitive like quantum
mechanics would satisfy
those inequalities whereas the epr pair
violates those in those bills
inequalities
and lo and behold alana spect
uh at the early eighties found uh gave
experimental evidence for this fact
so gave experimental evidence that
quantum mechanics really violates
uh those bell inequalities so it doesn't
behave it does behave
counter-intuitively
okay so these counter-intuitive things
can also be taken
one step further and
to the following scenario so suppose
alice has a state
and she wants to transmit this state to
bob but they're separated by some river
or something they're not
allowed to send quantum states in any
way so
still she can do it if somehow they
managed to meet before
and share a quantum epr pair so if they
managed to
to share this epr pair then it can serve
as a substrate
upon which every other quantum state can
be sent
if they only communicate classically
okay so here
this goes like this and even that
teleportation
was uh was uh checked and and
there's experimental evidence that you
know there are
teleportation over more than 150
kilometers now
uh various systems and um okay so so
uh so so in what sense do we say that we
don't understand quantum mechanics
i mean if we can take all these
principles and actually
uh play with them so nicely and
and predict expand predict experimental
results
and manage to actually perform those
experimental results and
everything works nicely um
then i would say we do understand
quantum mechanics
to some level at least the only
so what i would like to look to say only
for this talk and don't catch me
too strongly but only for this talk i
would like to say that this lack of
understanding of quantum mechanics is
sort of like
a spoiled kid lack of understanding we
understand we can do everything with it
but it's not to our liking because it
doesn't behave like what we would like
to behave
so we say we don't understand it but we
can
make all predictions so for this talk
i want to tell you about what we really
don't understand about quantum mechanics
so what we really don't understand
is the high complexity limit of quantum
mechanics
okay so what happens in quantum
mechanics when we add
many particles together when we put not
two particles together but n particles
together
so by the superposition principle if we
have we just have to look at all the
possible configurations of the particles
and and look at the states which are
superpositions of those
so how many configurations do we have
for um
one two three n particles for one we
have two configurations for two we have
four
each particle we add multiplies the
number of configuration by two
so eventually for n particles we have
two to the n possible configurations
and this is so mathematically there is a
nice description by tensor product of
in hilbert spaces describing uh each
the qubit but if you're not happy with
this description just
oops hard to see just view
just uh you just have to remember this
thing a quantum state of n particles and
quantum bits
in general is a superposition of
exponentially many
possible configurations and to describe
it you need to describe the coefficient
in front of each one of the two to the
impossible configurations
so this is this is really where quantum
mechanics
the difference between quantum mechanics
and classical mechanics goes to the next
level
why is that because classical systems
require only classical systems of n
particles require only
n or six n um numbers to describe if
you're talking about
say molecules in a gas you describe
momenta and location
six n parameters are enough for quantum
mechanics
you need two to the n parameters
so um so this is a really
humongous uh uh size of description
compared to this linear growth we have
this exponential growth of a description
and uh and this is what we really don't
understand in quantum mechanics it's
this
uh high complexity regime um
and and what i want to say by that is
that we really don't understand it
meaning it's not that we don't like it
but we don't have
good descriptions or good predictions
for for this regime
so um if you look at this hilbert space
of exponential size
um there's basically just a tiny little
fraction
of the states that have efficient
descriptions
just by counting arguments most of the
states
even even to very crude approximation
cannot even be pointed at
or let alone described simulated
etc or manipulated or predicted
so okay so
okay so this this boils down to uh
those states having much more
complicated entanglement structure than
uh um than even the the epr pair that we
didn't understand before
those most of the of the
data that we need to write down
basically lies down in the court in the
intricate correlations between those
particles
and we'll refer to that as
multi-particle entanglement
so um this sort of points at
uh at the difficulty of simulating
quantum mechanics which was uh noticed
already by feynman and independently by
manin and benoif
in the early 80s and it sort of
points to the very interesting
point of view of quantum mechanics which
is its relation to computational
complexity
there is an issue of quantum mechanics
of many many
of many particles which
sort of is problematic
from the computational point of view and
and so it suggests a new limit to look
at in physics
so we're used to looking at different
various limits in physics
um planck scale high energy
so this is a new limit to look at um the
high complexity regime
or the high computational complexity
regime
okay so
okay now um
this this uh hike this high complex
regime is not only a disadvantage of
course it's also an advantage this
lies at the heart of of uh of everything
that we know how to do in quantum
mechanics
in quantum computation um those highly
entangled states are crucial for
um for every for quantum algorithmic
speedups for example for
the factoring algorithm of shore or
other algorithms that you may not have
heard of like
graph reachability or approximating um
various not invariants and um
okay so so these highly entangled
quantum states are crucial there
and also crucial for all the other
phenomena that we encounter
in quantum phys in quantum computation
so uh
be it the security of quantum
cryptography or uh
the questions of which quantum systems
can we simulate
um or the notion of quantum error
correcting codes in which
it's very essential that we spread the
entanglement
over many many particles um
and it's also
and it's also uh crucial in the
difficulties of implementing quantum
computation
okay so so understanding highly
entangled quantum states
is really at the heart of both the the
things that we can achieve
in quantum computation complexity or in
quantum
uh by quantum computers or over our
studies of quantum computers and it's
also
at the heart of of the difficulties that
we encounter
and this is really what quantum tone
complexity is is about
it's really um the study of
of quantum states and quantum dynamics
of those states from a computational
point of view
okay so
so it's basically a marriage of
condensed matter physics and
computational complexity
where we take some from both so
in condensed matter physics there's many
many years of research
of specific examples very interesting
quantum states in quantum hamiltonians
with many many heuristics that were
derived and then from computer science
come various questions that we have
learned
to ask about highly complex
systems and now we can ask them about
those
physical systems so
if we put those together we sort of take
from condensed matter physics
the objects the local hamiltonians and
the ground states
and we ask about them questions that
come from
theoretical computer science like are
there efficient descriptions of those
states efficient
meaning polynomial what about algorithms
to
to map those states to other states what
about simulating quantum systems by
other quantum
systems or by classical systems and
reductions mapping
some those systems to others and and
this uh
this era which has been mainly going in
that direction
in the early days of quantum computation
um
where we only took the model and then
used it
for for algorithms this is now
also also now has um
its opposite direction and and basically
it's not just that the
edges of the two fields meet but it's
really the core
questions in both fields that are
tightly related in ways which
are really they're not artificial
they're very deep connections between
things
that uh that that might seem very very
different
on the surface okay so
so what i want to tell you about today
um in the remainder of the talk is um
is is trying to get at two main ideas
of of uh in this area and
from which various other ideas
uh branch and which which lie at the
heart of uh
of the three conferences that uh that
we're having in this program
now i've i've listed here three main
ideas
so the first one is testing quantum
mechanics which i'll talk about
robustness of quantum systems which i'll
talk about next and then
the last idea um actually i think that
ignacio uh we'll talk about in the next
open
lecture on on this uh on this program so
um i won't talk about that so
okay so so let's move on to
testing quantum mechanics what do i mean
by that
okay um
how to test quantum systems
computational view on the foundations of
quantum mechanics
um i'll try to explain this picture at
least
and it's based on various works i might
have forgotten some
um okay so so what's the question
let's look at a physical experiment um
in the most naive way how does a
physical experiment look
okay so we have some physical theory
that we want to test
now a usual physical experiment looks
like this
there's a theorist there is there's a
theoretician
and there is an experimental list and
the theoretician
takes the theory and makes some
prediction there's an experimentalist
who performs the experiment and then
they meet and there they compare their
results
okay and if there's a problem they throw
away the theory or they say
mostly that there was a problem with the
experiment and they try again
okay so um so
this is very naive this is how
experiments work
but if you look at it again you see that
actually
in quantum mechanics uh at least in the
high regime the high complexity regime
of quantum mechanics
this paradigm breaks down why is that
so let's look at a computational
complexity
point of view again from a computational
complexity point of view let's look
again at what i've said before
which you were happy with but let's just
phrase it
um from a different perspective so
okay so um what we said before
is that uh what we observe
is that quantum quantum evolutions
even quantum evolutions that take
polynomial time
seem very difficult to simulate
by classical evolutions so if we look at
the at the class of problems
which can be solved by classical
computer efficiently this is
denoted by ppp bounded point
probabilistic polynomial
but you don't have to remember that um
this seems to be strictly smaller than
the class
bqp which is the same but with quantum
computers
okay so those problems that i talked
about before
are here but we don't know that they're
here
okay so we think that these things are
different we think that they are
um so we widely believe that bqp is
strictly larger than bpp
and there's another belief that we add
to it which is that we believe that
those bqp evolutions those bqp
algorithms can in principle be
physically implemented
so we believe that there's no physical
obstacle to building a quantum computer
okay so
together what does do these things say
they say that we believe that there are
physical
evolutions that cannot be stimulated
efficiently
by classical computers okay so let's go
back to the physical
to the picture of the experiment and
explain it again
um okay so here's a physical experiment
we have those two
sides but now let's try to test quantum
mechanics at the high complexity regime
so we are placing here the theory by
quantum mechanics
and now the problem is this the
experimentalist can continue doing
whatever
he wants to do and perform the
experiment but
the theoretician part of the of the
story
cannot be achieved simply because we
cannot simulate
we cannot make a prediction according to
the theory because
we don't know how to simulate those
those evolutions okay so this is
this is sort of a very fundamental
observation
we cannot really test quantum mechanics
at the at the
uh the high complexity regime um
so experiments which test quantum
mechanics theory are supposed to be
compared to the predictions but we
cannot make those predictions so what do
we
compare things to okay so
um so the high complexity limit of
quantum mechanics cannot be tested using
the usual predict and compare
experimental paradigm which is
a disturbing thing because uh as far as
as i think most experiments if not all
lie in this predict and compare paradigm
um okay so um
so we see here the the uh the attempt to
to so this guy who's trying to tie the
tiger
uh is really trying to test or to trying
to come to command or to control
this highly complex system which he
can't really control
okay so so this question
leads to several uh
daughter questions so first hill is is
quantum mechanics
really falsifiable in the high
complexity regime at least
maybe maybe all the experiments that
we've done so far
only tested quantum mechanics in its low
complexity regime
and maybe there exists an alternative
quantum mechanical theory
which qm prime which agrees with quantum
mechanics and everything in the low
complexity regime
but does not have this exploding
computational complexity exponential
explosion
so can we so really the question is can
we experimentally test
all physical aspects of quantum
mechanics including its high complexity
regime
okay second question is more oriented to
the experimentalists
if you're trying if you're an
experimentalist and trying to build your
quantum computer
how do you actually test that it is
doing what you want
um if it's claimed to be a quantum
computer how do you know
okay and then a cryptographic
um aspect would be suppose you distrust
the the people that you're that you're
interacting with
and now you can ask how can you safely
buy a computer from an untrusted company
if she's
if it's telling you that it's a quantum
computer um how can you delegate
computations to this untrusted company
how can you provide a grant to an
untrusted experimentalist
so okay so
uh the alert listener might have
already uh noticed that uh there is a
partial answer to this
right i mean shor's factoring algorithm
provides
some partial answer because um it's a
point
outside of of uh it's it's a problem
that we believe cannot be
um solved by a classical computer
efficiently
but yet we can test it
okay so um um
so it provides a recipe for for an
experiment that's
outside of the of the um
usual scientific paradigm so what's
going on here um
okay it's some kind of a weird
experiment because it's not
so what's the difference difference is
that uh the the theoretician does not
have to predict the factors of the
number
um it has to just predict that the
verification process
of multiplying the numbers will will be
will result in exactly
n the number that we're trying to
factorize so this is a mild difference
but still it puts the experiment outside
of of of this
classical um of the of this class of
impossible experiments um
okay so yes it's not a good enough
answer why is that not a good enough
answer so first of all um factoring is
probably not
quantum universal um and secondly
what if i want to test a small quantum
system like 20
like uh i don't know 100 particles
it's even if it factors numbers it will
factor numbers that we can factorize
efficiently and uh and it's all it also
cannot really factorize
big numbers so how do i test it okay so
really we want to to provide
some some kind of a test to uh uh
for for larger for for a
more general class of uh quantum
evolutions in fact for
universal quantum evolutions for any
quantum evolution can we test
general quantum evolutions um
okay and the answer is yes using
fundamental ideas from computer science
you can you can test
the theory of quantum mechanics even
though we cannot make predictions
for it okay so so how does this go
um so let's look a little bit closer
into why
did shaw's algorithm for factoring
succeed even though
so even though it's not uh so succeed in
getting around the usual type of
experiment
pitfall so so the reason is that
really uh it's a
so to explain it maybe we'll look into
something which is
very similar to um to shore's
algorithm if you look at it correctly
and it's a very
profound idea in computer science and
that's called interactive proofs
okay so interactive proofs were invented
by goldwasser mikali and rakov
long ago in 85 and what are they
so imagine now a completely
imaginable entity of an all-powerful
prover
that is completely unlimited but is
untrusted
by the verifier who wants to verify some
claim
okay now they're allowed to interact
between them
and the verify wants to be convinced and
to use the
the the amazing power of the prover but
she doesn't trust him
and it turns out that uh um that this
the power of interactive proofs is
is much is much more powerful than
uh what she can do on her own so
the verifier can be convinced of things
much much more powerful
than she can uh resolve on
by herself and um
okay so so this is really um
a very interesting observation
and i want to first before before i'll
give some example of why this is true
i want to first
to first say wait um
to first say why schar's algorithm can
be viewed as a special example
for this thing okay so
um so it's not exactly a special example
but if you look at the prover and you
replace it by a quantum
uh by quantum computer which means it's
not all powerful but now it's more
powerful than the verifier the verifier
is still
a classical entity but now the prover
gets to be a quantum computer um
so now um if the quantum computer
interacts with a verifier
and tries to prove to it that uh the
factors of a number
are really p and q then
it just sends it to the verifier p and q
and the verifier only needs to multiply
them
and verifies them so it's a special very
redundant example
uh for the interactive proof with the
prover replaced by the quantum computer
okay so we'll get back to this of course
we we would ask whether
um this picture can help us in um
testing a general quantum evolution
but before let's understand why
interaction helps
okay so so this is a story of suppose
this is a story that had nothing to do
with with uh quantum physics
um suppose i have i i want to claim that
i know how to count the number of leaves
in a tree so there are nine billion
leaves in this tree i tell you um and of
course
you don't believe me i mean why should
you believe me so
here's a way where you can use
interaction in order to to
be convinced so you ask me how many
leaves there is in a tree i say say
three billion and a hundred okay so then
you ask me
turn around and you make sure i'm not
looking
and you pick a random number between say
one to ten
and say you got four
and you tear off four leaves of the tree
okay and then you ask me again to turn
around and you ask me again what's the
number of leaves in this tree
and if i tell you it's 3 billion and 96
then you say okay she knows maybe how to
do
something but maybe she got lucky so
or maybe she peaked so you you try again
and again and you make sure i'm not
peeking and
and if i succeed several times then um
you probably get convinced that i know
how to count
leaves in the tree even though you don't
know how to count beliefs in the dream
you can't verify the number so
um so this is how interaction and
randomness
can help you be convinced of things that
are
um that you can't do on your own
okay so so it turns out that you can
take this idea
and and uh um
and make it work for testing quantum
mechanical evolutions
um again using interaction and
randomness
so so the point here is really you
replace
the all-powerful prover by a quantum
computer and now you you're treating
your quantum system that you're making
ex
that you're trying to test as an
adversary okay so
you you want to think of it as the the
worst
thing possible that is trying to cheat
you in the worst way possible
now you're treating it as an adversary
and you're interacting with it
and and it turns out that by these
interactions with quantum provers
you can get convinced of whatever
evolutions the quantum
the quantum computer can perform even
though you cannot simulate it
um there's a caveat that you need you
need the internet you need to
actually hold a small number of quantum
bits um
and and trust those small number of
quantum bits but but still
you can using those the small number of
quantum bits you can
get to trust a full highly complex
quantum evolution
and this is related to to various
interesting ideas i just want to give
you
a very um sort of the beginning of of
the argument
of why why it would work um
so suppose suppose i'm thinking of a
much much easier
task which is this um
which is this i have a quantum bit and i
want to send it to a quantum computer
i don't know the state of the quantum
bit i want the quantum computer to
remember that state to keep it nicely
and then i want to get it back without
any change
but i don't know the quantum state that
i'm sending
okay so how can i make sure that the
state i've gotten is really the right
state
um
so here's a way that you could do it
suppose you have a one diamond
two dimensional herbert space that's a
state of a qubit you can encode the
state
of by some random code so you take this
two-dimensional manifold
and you map it randomly into some
two-dimensional sub-manifold
of a larger vector space
say for example by this map of
just for the sake of this description
take
psi and two more qubits at the state
zero zero and apply some random unitary
so this maps
this two-dimensional space into a random
two-dimensional space
and now when you get the state back you
can just test
that the state really belongs to the
random manifold
that you uh that you put it in by
applying
the unit the inverse unitary back and uh
and checking that the
that those qubits are really in the
state zero
okay so so the proofer cannot the
quantum computer who or whoever you're
interacting with
cannot really manipulate the state
because in order to do that
he needs to stay in this manifold but he
doesn't know where the manifold is
so it will probably get out of it and it
will be detected
okay so uh so it's crucial that the
manifold is random meaning that you're
using some random
encoding okay
so an open question is can a classical
verifier be convinced by quantum
mechanics
is it possible if i'm completely
classical to be convinced by the power
of quantum mechanics
and a partial answer was given
by rahat unga and vazirani last year
when where they showed that if if we can
assume that two quantum computers are
entangled
then the answer is yes um meaning if the
experimentalist or the verifier is
interacting with
two provers um or two quantum computers
which are assumed to
to have entanglement and other than that
they're separated
then um then one can use these
um these uh ep basically
um the assumptions on the height on the
very strong correlations on epr states
that i talked about before
in order to really verify that what they
have is the entanglement that they're
trying to generate
and again this is sort of a substrate of
entanglement and on top of that
you can perform any computation
okay so you can be convinced of a
general quantum computation that takes
polynomial time
we don't know whether this can be done
just by a classical proverb
interacting with a quantum verifier and
it's sort of it's a fundamental question
whether
classical mechanical system classical
systems can be
convinced that something quantum is
going on or that
quantum power computational power is
performed
um though they are completely classical
okay so the way i forgot to say the way
this is done
is by essentially by uh um
viewing these two computers as two
prisoners um
that uh if you want to to treat as a as
uh they're trying to cheat you well best
would be to separate them so that they
cannot coordinate their stories so this
is how you
despise buys you some power okay so
so this is related to um to many many
very interesting um questions that were
part of the focus of the of the
conference last week
which is uh for example certifiable
randomness where you
um where these uh these games that you
can play with epr pairs
and their measured output you can
actually certify
that this measured output is is random
is truly random
and it's also related to device into the
question of device independence
and we have a question of
um how how much you can rely on the
security of cryptographic protocols
if you don't know anything about how the
devices were
were built or what you can say about
them um
so you want security that does not rely
on this
and you can achieve that so um okay so
there are many many interesting branches
here
um i want to mention one thing which is
more general
than than just quantum computation
which is um
so this is um this point of view of an
interactive experiment can actually be
viewed as
more generally right i mean we often
talk about
experiments with systems that we don't
really understand
and maybe they're too hard to simulate
and the question is is it possible to
sort of generalize
this uh this idea to other systems that
might be very
difficult to understand and use this
more
structured paradigm of interactive of
interaction
um inspired by interactive proofs
to get to get some leverage of uh when
testing complicated physical systems or
biological systems or
what have you um so uh um
yo netanyahu um did his phd
in philosophy of science developing um
a theory of interactive confirmation
um and based on those
on those things and and uh um i don't
know i think
it might be very interesting to find um
other applications of those more
structured so so putting
experiments in a more structured way
into interactive
experiments
okay so so let me move on um
in the last eight minutes of the talk
to the second part which is um
which is the robustness of those
multi-particle entanglement states
okay so this is the based on on many
many things and then of course i'm not
going to cover
them all so
but i do want to give you one small idea
that's coming from there so really the
starting point
is is is a very
very much related to the previous point
which is
a verification of of claims
the notion of verification is is
something very profound in computer
science and
perhaps the most important
way to capture it is the class np
non-deterministic polynomial and um
okay you all even if you don't know this
you know this because
it's basically so here's an example
it's basically the class of problems
which if you're given a solution
you know that it's really a solution so
most problems
are like that or many many problems are
like that
thousands of problems are like that so
here's an example
you're given this graph and you're given
local constraints on this graph
each node can have a spin pointing up or
down
and the local constraints tell you if
the spins like to point
um this in the same direction or in
opposite directions
and so um so red
like to point in opposite directions and
green like to point in similar
directions
and you're asked whether there is a
configuration that satisfies
all constraints and here
i think there is no such configuration
but
this configuration violates one
constraint but obviously if you're given
such a configuration
you can and you're asked whether this
configuration um
really satisfies all constraints you can
test it you can check it
but given a graph it's very difficult
possibly very difficult
mainly if it's very very big to find
such a configuration even if it exists
okay so so this is an example of the
class of problems np
in which a solution if given can be
verified efficiently
but it might be very hard to find a
solution
okay um
so why should you care about this if
you're a physicist
or a chemist or someone who is not
interested in computer science
so it turns out that that
the very basic problem in computer
science which is
essentially a slight generalization of
of the problem i told you before
is simply a special case of the major
problem in condensed matter physics
okay so let's go back to the problem
that i mentioned before
um so imagine now that you're given
instead of a graph a slightly more
general thing which is
a set of local constraints on boolean
variables
and each such brackets corresponds to
such local constraints say on
two or three variables and you want all
of the constraints to be satisfied or as
many as
of the constraints as possible so this
is called
a csp formula constraint satisfaction
formula
and you're given such a thing and you
want to either minimize the number of
violations or
to find the optimal assignment or to
find some approximation you can
think of various things so this is a
generalization of this thing
it's also a generalization of the notion
of a mathematical proof you're given a
theorem
and you want to know if it's correct or
does there exist a proof of some limited
size for this theorem
this problem too is can be phrased in
this
way so it turns out that this
that this description is simply a
special case
of something which is at the heart of
condensed matter physics
which is the notion of a local
hamiltonian
so here is the the analog of the csp
problem
you're given a local hamiltonian which
is a hamiltonian acting say on
n particles in two state particles each
particle corresponds
replaces a boolean variable here and
and it's a sum of local constraints so a
local sum of local interactions each
interaction
involves only two or three or four
of the particles and and
what you want to do is you want to find
the minimal energy
state of this matrix or a state which
approximates it or the minimal
not only not just the ground state not
just the ground energy but also the
ground state or some approximations of
it etc
so this is simply a generalization of
this or this is a special case of this
and i want i won't say exactly how the
proof goes but you can
you can sort of see the connection um
basically by
viewing by replacing each constraint
here
by some energy terms which pro which
gives an energy penalty
if you violate this constraint so if you
take this
and phrase it in this language you get
constraints which are
commuting and in the computational basis
but the local hamiltonian problem
um which condensed matter physics is
facing
is is more general because the
constraints need not commute
and they may not be in the in the
computational basis in the
usual basis or in the same basis
okay so um
so the thing is that when we allow this
generalization
we enter again into this high complexity
regime of quantum states because the
ground states can now be
highly entangled so we can ask all those
questions about
about all those questions that computer
scientists
ask but now about those questions
from local from from connects matter
physics
with multi-particle entanglement
involved so so this
okay so what are what is the most
interesting question that we can ask
um that comes from computer science so
okay i'll tell you now perhaps the most
interesting
result from theoretical computer science
in the past uh 25 years
um so that we can try to take it and map
it to the quantum world
okay so if you if you haven't heard this
this is uh
this is uh quite shocking how many
people here have heard
about the pcp theorem okay
so um so for those of you who haven't
heard this is really
unbelievable um but it's true
it was proven a long time ago
no no no it's
actually maybe so
so what does the pcp theorem says pcp
for probabilistically
checkable proofs um so what it says
is this take your np problem and uh
remember mp is a set of problems which
can be
verified efficiently um
if you're given a solution you can
verify it but finding the solution is
difficult
okay so this is the verifier who is
supposed given a solution
here there's x which is missing and y is
the
suggested solution and the verifier is
supposed to be able to take the solution
and verify that it really is a solution
so think of a mathematical
theorem and a mathematical proof and the
verifier
is supposed to verify the mathematical
proof so then the pcp theorem says that
there is
a way to translate this verifier to a
new verifier
which takes who takes
a slightly longer input
a theorem which is translated to a
slightly longer version
such that if you're given the proof
a proof for this theorem it suffices to
read only
a constant number of bits from this
proof to be convinced
what if the proof is correct or not so
if you're
reviewing articles this is really
something that you need to remember from
this talk
except it's not practical yet
but it's not i don't know if it's far is
it far from practical
now
yeah so that sounds like building a
quantum computer
answer okay so so uh
so we're working on i mean people are
working on that
but um but uh but in theory
um these translations are efficient and
and this this is completely remarkable
that really there is a way to map
um mathematical theorems
in to such a formula to such a format
that
the mathematical proofs of those
theorems can be
verified by just looking at a small
number of places
which basically means that um okay let's
let's
let's first see the the way it's written
so np is equivalent to the class of
languages in which the verifier reads
only
a constant number of bits from the proof
random
and there's a different way to phrase it
which is um
the set of problems that we were talking
about before the
np-hard problems like finding the up the
the finding a configuration with uh
with energy smaller than some number for
that graph
um well this problem is equivalent
to a problem which seems much much
easier which is
distinguish between whether the graph is
completely satisfiable
or that is you can satisfy all
constraints
or you have to violate at least 10
percent of the constraints
so approximating the number of necessary
violations to within 10 percent
is as hard as finding the number of
violations that you need to value
so okay now how does this
how does the proof go i'm not going to
get into um
it looks a bit like uh like hologram so
it looks a bit like
you you have you're taking a proof with
a problem in it
a small problem and then you sort of
spread it all over the place
and now wherever you look there's a
problem if there was a problem in the
beginning if there wasn't any problem
nothing happens so okay
by far okay i think this is the most
influential result in theoretical
computer science over the past 25 years
there's many many
applications to it
and maybe from a physics perspective
i would like to say that that whereas
the issue of finding ground states is
empty heart this was known long long ago
by barahona
finding those optimal
assignments to two graphs that i showed
you before
the pcp theorem says that even reaching
the gibbs distribution
at room temperature is np hard so for a
system to relax
there are systems such that for them to
relax to their gifts distribution
they need to solve an extremely
difficult problem so it will take them
exponentially long to relax to their
gibbs distribution
now there are complicated systems but
there are such systems
so this is what the pcp theorem says it
tells you how to construct such
such systems um okay
and this is what i call this is what i
mean by robustness
this hardness is maintained also at room
temperature
a different way to say it is that it's
spread all over the place
so the problems are spread all over the
place okay
um a problem and a proof is spread all
over the place okay so so um
as i said i'm not going to give the the
proof of the
of the pcp theorem it's highly complex
and and
quite long and and but
but to the physicists and chemists in
the audience
a possible way to think about it is
something like a renormalization group
approach where
uh you start from from a small problem
and then you do summary normalization
step
and spread the problem a little bit to a
lot to a slightly larger scale
and then you repeat and
this sort of makes the problem spread
all over and the only thing is that
well in order to do that you encode the
problem into more bits
and you somehow make sure that they are
encoded in a structure which
can be tested locally so uh
so that uh sort of if if it's not in the
structure you will find it everywhere
um or easily okay so so
this is sort of a picture of making the
problem
um larger and then you somehow have to
reduce back to your original size of
constraints
okay so you're not supposed to really
understand this this is just to give you
some intuition um and then the question
is is there a quantum piece of
theorem and uh um
i'm not going to give you the exact form
i mean the formulation of what a quantum
pcp theorem looks like
but i think i've given enough
introduction to
to give you an intuition of what what
that would be and well think of
an attempt to smear a problem all over
the place
but now you have to do it for states
which are multi-entangled so for
states of many many particles which are
highly entangled
highly correlated all over the place
and unfortunately we have no idea how to
do it
there's just uh um nothing of the
classical technique
techniques seem to work and i want to
end my talk
with trying to give you some um
some peek into why that is true because
it's uh
it's a it's a very fundamental thing
that we encounter
again and again when we uh when we
handle
multi-particle entanglement entangled
state
okay so so the real issue is the notion
of
is the problem of of of the fact that
multi-particle entanglement has uh
a global versus local
issue meaning that states which are
highly entangled could look locally the
same
but globally could be completely
different because entanglement is
something that is spread
all over the place and here's an example
take your
take the epr pair that i've talked about
before slightly modified now it's
instead of up down minus down up it's up
up
minus down down it has the same type of
entanglement
and so this would be the uh say the
minus state
so up up up up up minus down down down
and then consider
another state which is the same except a
plus here
so these two states is easy to see
they're orthogonal
but if you look at them locally
each qubit behaves like completely
random state
so um locally they are the same but
globally
they're autobahn they're completely
different and this is
really uh the essence of of the problem
because we are handling things
locally coming from classical intuition
everything we do is local
but we cannot even distinct between
orthogonal states
globally between completely different
states
so nothing seems to work now
really this boils down to understanding
what types of entanglement we can
encounter and i'd like to point at
uh and this brings me to to the topic of
the third conference
um so the pcp the question of pcp would
be uh an important part of the of the
second conference
or okay so right is that
and this brings me to the topic of the
third conference which is
you would like to understand better
quantum states so really the question of
quantum pcp can be
made much much simpler and still we
don't know the answer to it
what hamiltonians have ground states
which with
robust entanglement so even if we don't
care about the mapping between the
original homitory and the next the
the final hamiltonian the translation
between
one formal format of the theorem to the
next
the quantum theorem to the next even
forget about the mapping and just ask
what kind of hamiltonians
can be the final hamiltonians
what kind of hematomas have robust
entanglement in their ground states
we don't know how to construct such
hamiltonians you might have heard of
topological order
and and this might look like
a good candidate but it's not i'm happy
to explain later why
um offline but um but really
we can ask a much more general question
can we classify
entanglement the structure of
entanglement that are possible in ground
states of hamiltonians
in any useful way and understand what
kind of entanglements
appear there so such that we can
manipulate them um
in in efficient ways or in any way that
we understand
so let me point now to the uh lecture
on this topic or related topics uh
that's going to happen in maine that's
the second open question on on this
open uh open lecture on uh on the
quantum
and complexity program and thank you for
your attention
so i'm one of the newbies here who
hasn't heard about pcp before
so i know my question is a little bit
naive but it seems there are two aspects
the second one that you mentioned is
that we say it is as hard to find as 10
percent
approximation energy as the run state
anyway
intuitive i can feel that's probably
okay but it's certainly nothing to
celebrate about
but then the other part was that you
find in somewhat larger description of
the problem
and that actually then helps you maybe
at some time in the future finding the
solution because you only have to sample
you know a finite number of bits
can you elaborate how that might help
friends to find
the solution to a traveling salesman
problem
no no the point is that you
you only say that a problem that seems
easier
is actually as hard as the traveling
salesman problem it's not that
these are bad news you're right in the
beginning these are not
good news um i mean they're they're good
in the sense that we know
better what is going on but uh but i
wouldn't say that
these things are really hard yes they're
even hard when you only
try to approximate it like really
crudely
um yes um
so
okay so really hastings conjecture
hasting post a conjecture which said
that
uh there exists a family of local
hamiltonians such that
not only its their grounds the ground
state of of each hamiltonian family is
highly entangled and by
i can tell you what highly entangled is
later but not only that
but also all low energy states below
energy
say 10 10 of um
where m is the number of constraints so
m over 10 energy less than m over 10 are
still all highly entangled
so i'm sorry why is there a family in
this discussion
oh because you need to um you need yeah
the size goes to infinity
okay so and we don't know how to
construct such hamiltonians we all
so for example in torah code um it seems
like they're
or topological order states which have
their entanglement structure related to
topology
they seem to be good candidates for for
uh robust entanglement because topology
is robust and
and they're known to be robust in many
many different senses
but it's not they're not robust in this
sense because you can easily
find um not ground energy states
but low energy states but by violating
only
um only the constraints along the red
lines and
by violating only those you can find
easily ground states which are only
locally entangled
just find the ground state of this thing
and this thing and this thing etcetera
and tensor product
so they are not good candidates and
anything on the lattice will not be a
good candidate because of this argument
maybe ignacio is uh a better uh person
to answer
this question do you want
to learn trying to build some experience
to simulate the power models of models
that are interesting
from the condensed cycle point of view
to see how electrons move
and things like that
yeah this is kind of true when people
say that we don't understand quantum
mechanics
they're saying that we don't really
understand how to write down a
measurement
in like a fully quantum system right so
no no i said only for this talk i'm
saying that it's kind of uh
i mean this is sort of um a spoiled
uh approach to saying and i'm not under
there there are different levels of not
understanding
this regime we really don't understand
because we have no idea how to work with
it and make predictions
in the sense of in the problem of in the
measurement problem
we don't understand it but we can make
all predictions
so i i find it different
conceptually yeah so
uh
in which you propose that this high
entanglement regime is sort of a
different limit
physics and all the other limits you
would say some things become simpler
is there any expectation that some
things become simpler here i think this
is an excellent question
um i don't know
i mean to the best of our knowledge i
don't
see how it becomes simpler but maybe
from a different point of view it might
become simpler
i don't know
um
thanks very much